hello Internet my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara's never seen
today I am watching the 1982 horror
classic poltergeist this is a movie I
wanted to watch last year for Tam tober
fest and just didn't have enough weeks
for so I'm doing it this year I'm very
excited to see it it's another like
scream where it's one that I should have
seen and Rosemary's Baby and the
Hellraiser films guys I just don't see
films apparently ever
yes that's my thing great I wrote
poltergeist predictions and all caps
because of excitement and then gift Jeff
I'm super excited to jump into this one
so let's do it
towba first good that wasn't what I
thought how do these things not get
ruined for me I do not know but when I
saw all of the promotional pictures for
this and the girl against the screen I
just assumed it was gonna be about like
kind of like a VHS kind of thing like
don't watch the tape or I don't know
like I don't know how did this not get
ruined for me kind of like it's like a
ghost haunting of a house that's a
poltergeist okay I'm putting it together
I think the special effects were lacking
a bit like whenever the poltergeist
would come out and it's ghostly form as
the tornado a couple times you see is
pretty cheesy but the practical effects
are insane how does a tree eat a kid
yeah also the characters are so goddamn
relatable in this film it's nuts it
blows me away the whole time I was
writing down notes like this is me I am
this person I am the dog walking around
the house at night prowling for snacks
in all of the rooms to me I'm also the
grown adult biking in a sweaty sweat
suit with an arm full of beer and I am
deaf boom net to lead the little girl
burying her dead pet with a bunch of
little trinkets for the afterlife I
buried my dead rat yogurt in the six
with blankets and celery and treats and
a game my social security no probably my
favorite part of the bill is when the
parents have put the kids to sleep
they're both in bed together and they're
smoking weed it's so casual I don't know
why that delighted me to my very core
but it delighted me to my very core
question though the parents are
obviously cool as hell and the kids
aren't you they've got Star Wars pajamas
and blankets and toys and Captain
America comics who bought them that
clown doll who is them but them that
clown doll was it an ant I bet it was an
ant cheesy ghost is cheesy
but the therehere line is great oh that
gets under your skin in such a good way
I just love all of the characters in
this when the mom discovers that the TV
people are moving the chairs around she
gets super stoked about it
her husband comes home and she's like
remember when you were open-minded try
to get back to that place keep an open
mind for what you're about to see and
then she scoots her tribe along where
the chairs slide in it's great so I
wrote down that tree is creepy as crap
and then two seconds later holy shit
literally two seconds after I wrote that
it ate the kid then the roommates the
little girl oh my my god the swimming
pool the swimming pool
Natha she's in the TV so the paranormal
investigators come and they show them
the room where everything's flying
around and again very cheesy effects
when it's like special effects are not
done practically but I love the splash
of comedy in this scene they're like
we're professionals we do this Lyttleton
and we've captured such great stuff and
the dad like uh-huh and then opens it
and if you like shaking for the rest of
the scene it's so good it's all just
very casual while still being very
invested like you're still very invested
in it but the family's pretty cash like
they're pretty casual about there being
a poltergeist who has taken their
daughter and now she's living inside the
house like in the wood of the house like
not in house like
like in the like the veins of the house
but again I wrote holy hell acting is so
so good when Carolyn moves through the
mom and the sister is crying they could
smell Carol Anne and the mothers face
and the sisters over there bawling in
their books it's just amazing also
that dog deserves an Oscar Elsa love
that getting Carolyn back is keeping
them in the house versus a lot of
hunting movies it's just like just have
this really weird attachment to this
house we can't leave I don't know why it
wouldn't make sense would it ha ha ha
people die here
okay so steak also that face ripping
scene is a mixture of a really cool
dream and also really bad specialist are
practical effects and but they just work
somehow it definitely holds up other
than the tornado and the weird ghosty
poltergeists that come out around the
house that I think other than those
things it really holds up again I say
something is me they bring the psychic
in and it's me y'all y'all mind hanging
back get Jenna so they bring this
special psychic in and she's gonna get
Carol Ann out of the house and they
opened this portal and Carol Ann's
closet and they throw rope in and the
mom has to go in and get her and it's
weirdly romantic like
uncharacteristically romantic for a
weird stress closet scene to be so
romantic like the mom and dad kiss and I
felt things about heart I don't even
really know what happened in this whole
sequence there's a lot of stuff
happening and a lot of portal things I
just didn't really understand but it was
excellent and the special effects were
better in this scene than the others I
wrote down me after chores from now on
this house is
then the clown doll attacks and then
there's skeletons in the pool so you
find out that the housing development
that their home is on is on top of a
cemetery huge yeah that's where all of
these skeletons are coming from there's
a cool AF hallway shot where it's just
really along gates and the moms are
running down it to get her children it's
awesome you son of a bitch headstones
you only moved the headstones the
gravestones popping out a really cool
though he just said that he had moved
the house effect kind of imploding on
itself was awesome I loved the end where
they're staying in a hotel and he throws
the TV out it was really really good so
there's others in the poltergeist series
there's more than one film are they with
the same people are they different
people experiencing a poltergeist that's
a thing to happen in the 80's and 90's
with horror films is I mean it's still
happening now the conjuring but at least
those are good films they would make a
decent horror film and then they would
make 70 hundred million sequels Wyatt
Wyatt Wyatt why because money that's why
I answered my question good job Tamara
thanks Tamara you're welcome to you'll
end up feeling a strong bond for the
family by the end absolutely I cannot
believe in which I loved these
characters they were funny and heartfelt
and well-written and well acted ah yes
you'll either love it or think it's just
alright that's generally how these go
for me I don't know that I've ever hated
one before the medium woman will be your
favorite character because she's the
best true that's just science
you won't watch static TVs the same when
have I ever watched a static TV I grew
up in the 90s watching this on TV I
assume engaging click you'll get sucked
right in a tip of the hat to you sir I
see what you did there having
experienced the whole paranormal
activity craze you will find
poltergeists premise much
exciting I've only seen the first
paranormal activity but I found it to be
really boring you will notice the most
awkward cut to the next scene in any
movie predictions are still open they
are still open and no I didn't because I
don't notice anything you guys teach me
your ways just type in poltergeist
cursed into Google and you'll learn a
lot okay
claim the poltergeist film series is
cursed and has seen several strange
deaths occur among its cast members Oh
No oh the two girls died two other
people died but they had serious
illnesses say ignorance is not trying to
be disrespectful I just don't know how
to say work thank you so much for
watching you guys
I loved that next week I'm talking about
the Hellraiser films notably at number
one I'll be talking about the most but
all of them recently I watched all nine
of the Hellraiser films you guys in one
day that's the that's the big key
element I missed telling you all of them
in one day Rosemary's Baby
scream the poltergeist and then the
Hellraiser films I think that's a pretty
solid Tam Tobin fest if you ask me thank
you so much for watching I'll see y'all
next week bye here
[Music]
[Applause]
you